i had this crazy thing happen i went to
the um gathering of the juggalos oh
right i was i hosted the main stage like
that in the bucket list gathering of the
juggler the most incredible
faygo i come out i come out on stage and
and i'm doing like crazy tricks and
stunts whatever all i'm hearing from the
crowd show us your butthole
sure is your butthole and i'm like at
first i was confused and then you know
that's where it went out and then i i
mentioned something no no they love it
they like they love it they really they
they really
mean it they want to see your butthole
they love by the way i'm never liked uh
insane clown bossy fans more than right
now right so
my natural reaction to that as well i
mean if that's what they want and that's
they care about that like who am i to
deprive them of them so my next time i
go out on the stage and
i [ __ ]
i spread my butt cheeks like
like then
past the point of where it hurt and he
gave him a heads up too so they all
pulled their phone out are you serious i
had no issue with that i had no problem
with that yeah this was this was for
them now and on top of that there's like
a whole you know like the media
game between the crowd and the stage
yeah yeah oh dude pull on and the next
the next day
shaggy who's one of the i i met him i
met him yeah he um
he sends me a
photo that was taken from the crowd
because man you weren't kidding about
and this photo is the most shocking
[ __ ] thing you have it on you dude
like it's the most [ __ ] shocking
thing you've ever seen yeah he talked
about it for a good like two minutes
that he's going to show his butthole so
everybody's just ready to go
and here's the end result okay let like
i'm gonna in my text i'm going to
search the word cavernous
really
big paper
because
is my face turning red what's going on
down there were you pushing or like were
you sucking in or something
i showed my girl and and uh
she's like you can fit the whole
microphone in there like that's an
o-ring that's like a [ __ ]
but it's not but that's the thing is
that it's not
[ __ ]
my butthole
it's the lighting it's the lighting can
i tell you i'm really impressed by their
lighting on that stage right i really
like this i think i use similar lighting
in my stage i'm not even joking yes how
happy he's got it
awesome
yeah so was that photo online um
yeah
it's gotta be online are you kidding me
who takes that picture and doesn't post
it right that person posted that photo
that's not good
they don't think they're like this one's
for me that's like the top of the seo
yeah it's the stuff of legends now did
you did you hear the story about how
scott randolph types in
johnnyknoxville.com and finds it to be
available for purchase
no and i [ __ ] bought it
are you serious yeah
okay watch this
i'm gonna type in johnny knoxville.com
all right it'll it'll just it should
just pop right up
and
johnnyknoxville.com it's got an age gate
the first thing you see is uh are you
18.
and uh
man how do you not have a good cell
phone signal at your own house it's the
tree
we have a great wife okay are you over
18. yes
um
and we made we made it a particularly
small okay you know that i'm going to
show you what [ __ ]
what loads up dude because i have it
nice and handy
hi i'm johnny
oh that's [ __ ] great
[Music]
that's [ __ ] awesome
is that your butthole yeah
but it looks like it is because of the
same shirt
yeah i think that clip was awesome but
not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what i've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions which
is out september 27th and if you
pre-order it right now you can get the
autographed copy so get on it man
pre-order my book it's not going to
waste your time because i'm proven dude
new york times bestseller my first
book's five star rated on amazon and i
have no doubt this one will be two so
get the autographed copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude